really exciting day today we're
expecting delivery of a high magnetic
field stm fm that also goes down to
temperatures about a factor of 10 and
temperatures we've we've been able to
achieve here previously
it's been a long time coming it's about
two years various delays due to um
oh however reported political
developments and then covet have really
um pushed this this project back quite a
lot so we've been waiting a very very
long time so i'm delighted that this day
has finally arrived so in this
nicely refurbished new lab we're going
to have the new
stm fm system in this space as you can
see it's empty right now um up here is a
camera that's going to capture the
various stages of construction of this
system it's an ultra high vacuum system
it's a very it's a low temperature
system as well so there's lots of
stainless steel bits to assemble like a
massive big lego puzzle and um that's
what's going to occupy us for the next
few days
[Laughter]
chap's just um tying the
the lorry closer into the wall
we're obviously going to unload from the
side doors of the vehicle here and then
we're going to use the forklift to
transport the crates just up the hill
there
and then we struggle with pallet trucks
to get it into the building
[Music]
exactly yeah yeah exactly sort of just
in the early stages of bringing stuff in
these particular boxes are the
controller that really is at the heart
of it um in terms of controlling the stm
so oh it's started raining of course it
has how many of these systems have you
installed of unicircle systems in
general in in europe um
okay well this is the first in the uk
that's true
so all the crates are off the lorry um
they're being undrilled all the bolts
are being taken out at the moment i will
get a drill in my hand and start helping
out i promise we're just trying to sort
of drill bit at the moment
so you can take one out oh the other one
should be left in until we can see just
one one of each of these okay perfect
okay but any on the top you can take out
[Music]
you know where you are when you've got a
power drill in your hand
[Music]
we planned it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so it's day two of the installation and
a huge amount has changed already so all
this wooden platform that was there
we're gonna have to rebuild that
platform because at the moment it's
slightly dangerous this magnet has been
dropped in that magnet is about the same
height as i am will be filled with
liquid helium but 90 liters of hit
liquid helium in there the um
uhv the ultra high vacuum chambers have
been added on top everything's been
trained in it's been um
really really fun to watch this all
emerge and to see it here now after sort
of waiting for two years for this to
happen is great is is just just
wonderful the other great thing about it
is the um guy who's really
worth standing back and watching them do
all this stuff because like a magician
like a master magician in terms of
assembling this guy called thomas
berghaus thomas
did his phd right at the start at the
birth at the origin of stm and the group
he was in was one of the groups that was
quickest to follow on from the ibm
invention of the the scanning tunneling
microscope and pick up and get that
technology and start build their own stm
the hard stuff in the beginning normally
goes pretty quick
and then there will be days where uh
the tiny things are going to be
happening so like assembling the stm to
the cryostat and the wiring and
everything and
then you do one wire per hour or
something and nobody
will see what you're doing really great
to talk with thomas because he was
responsible for designing the stm1 the
omicron stm1 that i use for my phd we
will assemble a lot of components like
the titanium supplement like the lead
optics the sputter iron gun
then we will assemble the transfer
manipulators and
when we then have all flanges closed
with
some function and
so then we will pump it down and leak
check and uh next step will be then
go for uh 3 with the bake out and
everything and
yeah before do some tests with the sdms
and
eventually then
after the bake out cool the thing down
and
yeah then the great overcomes
[Music]
okay
so it's chamber and we can go on the
other side of this chamber
um which is going to have to be lifted
in over the top
oh it's high enough it's not quite high
enough to clear it
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay
thank you sean
touchdown
okay thank you
so yeah we've just trained in this
chamber which um ultimately is going to
have this thing on top of it going all
the way down
um directly above the magnet
um and we're going to see all that come
together over the course of the next few
i'd like to say days but it's going to
be weeks really
probably a month before we're going to
see atoms
so we are going just down to see the um
the microscope now we're at day
13. thomas has now left to go back to
germany thomas and uh japanese engineers
so the company that supplies the
instrument is a company called unisoco
uh will be back in 15th of november
when we'll start the the system will be
at a good vacuum at that stage okay so
you can feel it's really hot in here oh
wow um
and the reason it's really hot in here
is because
well things have first of all things
have changed a lot haven't they since
the last time you were here
tables in place magnets down there
this long transfer tube's in place the
whole thing is covered with tin foil
because we're heating it up and the
reason we're heating it up is because
ultimately
i'll take that off ultimately um we want
to get to what's called an ultra high
vacuum in here i've talked about this in
other 60 symbols videos at length but
what we're doing is we're heating up the
system and the tin foil is there just to
keep everything nice and toasty um
the key contaminant if we don't do this
is water the internal surface is all
covered with a very thin film of water
and if we don't heat and pump that water
just stays there for months if not years
and just leaks off the walls gradually
and pollutes our vacuum what we're doing
now is we're boiling off the water
basically accelerating the process
pumping it all away so when everything
cools down after about a week
um
we'll get a much better vacuum and then
our pressure will be
oh
about a million million times
um lower than atmospheric pressure
comparable to the pressure you get on
the moon and on a good day maybe even
comparable to the pressures you get in
some regions of deep space so it's a
pretty low pressure and we need those
vacuums because we want to work with
atomically
clean samples
if we want contaminants there or if we
want molecules on the surface that
aren't part of this you know the
original material
uh that's because we want to introduce
them we don't want you know oxygen just
and other contaminants from the air co
etc and indeed water landing on our
sample and polluting it so this is why
we we work this hard to get the vacuum
where does the water go
the water gets pumped away by the pumps
so basically by turbo pumps uh so by um
there are pumps down here which are
basically coming along here it's coming
along these tubes and then out the
exhaust of this this pump down here so
it just gets all pumped away
that's a very happy wheel
did they provide the foil they even
provided the foil
wonderful absolutely wonderful
so our day 45 been up for day for 45
days in a row with this that's not
really it reached to its base
temperature which is about 300 milli
kelvin which is about 10 times colder
than
out in the deepest darkest depths of the
universe because the cosmic microwave
background radiation is around 2.7 k we
have yutaka visiting us from the company
unisocker who's the ceo of the of
unisoco who um has
played an absolute storm or has been
incredibly good and another magician
like thomas in terms of getting the
system up and running training us on how
to use it to get down to those type of
temperatures we first of all liquid
nitrogen and liquid helium lots and lots
of liquid helium that goes into that
massive magnet and the stm is down here
right at the bottom all the way down
here or close to the bottom the stm this
is a very i think you saw this before
when it was out this insert that goes
down there to get down to 300 milli
kelvin um we use something called helium
3 a bottle of which
let me see there we go
this is now pretty much empty not
entirely empty but pretty much empty
because it's in there at the moment
actually it's going in the system
that's about 30 000 pounds so as thomas
said you pay for
helium-3 which is an isotope of helium
by the atom it's extremely expensive
but barring any disaster which we can
never rule out we basically um the the
helium 3 can be effectively recycled
it's
absorbed and then
turns into the gas phase and is
reabsorbed and condensed and then goes
back into the gas phase etc so but it's
an expensive business and liquid helium
helium 4 is also not
particularly
inexpensive either and it's actually a
dwindling resource so
we are i am very conscious of um
uh all these various issues let's put it
that way we are at i believe day 65
um and we've been left on our own the
training wheels are off the attacker
worked extremely hard for four weeks or
so um really doing all the commissioning
and all the site acceptance in terms of
what are the noise levels does the
magnet work when we go up to the highest
fields does everything cool and yes
everything cools and down to 320 milli
kelvin which as i might have mentioned
before is 10 times colder than the
cosmic microwave background radiation in
the universe so the leftover remnants of
the big bang radiation um
uh
so that's that's that's a pretty cold
place down in that magnet um can be a
pretty cold place in the universe not
only does it get down to that
temperature it gets down to that
temperature and stays there for 63 hours
what we see is our hold time is 63 hours
that's
that's very helpful for us it allows us
to do prolonged experiments what we'd
really like to do is to take the tip
which is coated with gold atoms because
we've deliberately crushed into the
surface and then go dutch and drop down
an atom and dutch and drop down another
atom and die and if we could do that
that would be a little short and magical
it would be really neat however what
happens is that yes on occasion and let
me change the contrast here
we can indeed put down single atoms
these little features but also the
problem is sometimes when we do exactly
the same process
larger clusters appear
so we we we have some degree of control
but not a great degree of control over
just how many gold atoms we put down but
the good thing is that there's a
reasonably high probability of putting
down single
gold atoms and then what we want to do
is then try and shunt those across the
surface so these lines in the background
well imagine taking a crystal in this
case it's gold but it could be pretty
much any crystal
and you slice that open to expose a
surface now the atoms that are at that
surface are much less happy than they
were when they're in the bulk
because when they were in the bulk they
interacted with their neighbors they
have a certain valence they want that
valence they have a certain number of
bonds they want to form but when you
hack through the the um the crystal to
expose that surface
not always hacking through sometimes
it's a little bit more nuanced and
careful than that but when you expose
that surface those atoms at the surface
are
in a different state than the atoms in
the bulk and they're much more reactive
their energy is higher so what they will
do
um
is move around as much as possible
usually given the constraints of how
much thermal energy there is
but they will move around to try and
minimize their energy to try to somehow
drop back down into a situation that
gets them closer to where they were in
the bulk in terms of the overall energy
and that's a process called surface
reconstruction and it's absolutely
fascinating because
so many different surfaces form a range
of different reconstructions here's
here's an example of one really pretty
one which is very famous that's just one
example there are literally thousands
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of different patterns out
there that the atoms can find and this
is one of them this is another famous
one this is called the herringbone
reconstruction of gold what you have
here is these larger or these brighter
regions
there's effectively a rumpling in the
surface so that some atoms move up some
atoms move down it's a very very small
rumpling and again they're doing that to
try to relieve the strain to try to
bring their energy back down and this
reconstruction is very famous
in terms of
uh
it's a very stringent test
of the the stability of a microscope and
the resolving power of the microscope in
terms of can you resolve that
herringbone can you um see that without
a great deal of noise so the tip's
moving back and forth and it's measuring
uh we're telling it to keep the current
between the tip and the sample constant
and to keep that current constant what
it has to do is move back and forth and
follow the topography of the surface
because it's a feedback loop and it's
comparing the current value
it's comparing the value of the current
it's measuring against the value of the
current you want which we call the
setpoint current that feedback loop has
a certain response time so if you drive
past the point at which the feedback
loop can respond
it can at worst case crash so yeah this
is the tunnel current that it's
measuring and this is the motion of the
zed how do we get such fine control over
the position of the tip because we need
to move to be able to measure not down
to the atomic limit but actually that
precision better than the diameter of
the atom of an atom
so we use piezoelectric elements
those sound like rather esoteric
technology but they're not you know
those barbecue lighter things that you
go click click and it gives you a spark
at the end and you light your barbecue
what those are is in the handle of those
is a piezoelectric crystal and in that
case what happens the property of the
piezoelectric crystals is when you
distort them when you strain them you
build a big voltage up across them it
can actually be kilovolts many kilovolts
that's voltage is large enough to break
down air so you get the little spark um
turn that idea in its head
and perhaps use piezos that are a little
bit higher quality than those you get in
barbecue lighters and if you apply a
voltage to the piezoelectric crystal it
will distort
and you can if you've got good high
voltage amplifiers no low noise high
voltage amplifiers and good crystals
then you can control the position of the
tip down to the picometer level that's a
hundredth of the diameter of an atom you
can see here these air legs are in place
to try to decouple or to decouple the
instrument from this the surrounding
building because we're trying to work
down at a level as i've just said of
fractions of an atomic diameter the
floor in which you're standing shown and
which well i'm sort of sitting um is
oscillating up and down vibrating on the
down at the level of microns so about a
million times bigger in terms of the the
the amplitude of those oscillations than
the type of precision we want to get to
so we need to decouple the system from
the the external building and one key
way of doing that is with these
pneumatic legs which lift the entire
system up so it's supported by those
legs so these are the same this is where
the samples are introduced this is
called a load lock
we'd um open this up we'd unscrew this
we put our sample in on the end of this
arm
then we pump this down
then we'd open that valve
then we'd move our sample into this
chamber and then we bring this one in
to couple with that pick it up take this
arm back shut this off so now it's back
it's not it's isolated from this load
lock and we can then wait for the
pressure to recover and then we can take
our sample and bring it all the way in
here to this monstrous beast of a
transfer arm
all the way up there
and then to transfer samples into the
microscope they're at the end of this
arm and then we're going to go all the
way down to the bottom of the magnet
well close to the not quite the bottom
of the magnet but close to the bottom of
the magnet we're looking at individual
atoms those atoms are fairly weakly
bound because you can see even here the
atom that it's like
it's got discontinuities in it it's got
wobbliness in it because the tip is
interacting um with the atom and sort of
dragging it and shifting its position a
little bit
interesting question is what color is an
atom so important thing to realize with
scanning for a microscope is a
microscope like no other we have that
tip and our image is based on the
current that's flowing between the tip
and the sample
and it's a quantum mechanical tunneling
current
um
this is quantum mechanics in action
you're seeing here but the microscope
itself has no optics no lenses no
mirrors it's it's not imaging in the
sense that a traditional microscope
images and our image is based on the
amount of current we measure at
different parts in the image that's
that's basically what it is so we can
define whatever color scheme we like so
at the moment our atoms are sort of
ready yellow
if you want them sort of a bit blue
there they go if you perhaps prefer to
have them a bit sort of coppery like
that or maybe um even a sort of slightly
different goalie
does that look gold to you looks more
green to me let's see what winter's like
oh winter's like that and philippe's
developed to put together his own
palette which is called the good one
which looks um
red and yellow again you see these sharp
changes
see this chart where it looks like the
the atom has been sliced
that's because it's interacting with the
tip
um these other shadowy features are
probably almost certainly you see each
one's got a tiny little ghost image
you get used to seeing these things
sometimes it's difficult to spot them
but this tiny little ghost very faint
ghost is probably because we've got a
slight double on our tip
so of course as soon as you left started
to work incredibly well almost as soon
as you went out the door
so
let me turn the screen view around the
camera view ran so you can see what's
going on
so i've spent a few happy hours
depositing atoms from the tip
these all these features that are
roughly the same size are individual
almost certainly gold atoms that come
off the tip but we've crushed the tip
quite heavily into the gold sample so
the tip is covered with gold atoms we've
got a reasonably high probability when
we touch the tip into the sample of
depositing a single gold atom actually i
believe this one which is slightly
bigger than the rest the eagle eyed
among you might be able to spot i
believe this might be a dime or maybe
two gold atoms
but we also have a probability for
putting down rather more than one gold
atom and that's what these little
clusters are these brighter features so
it is now where's the bloody camera down
there isn't it so it is now
20 plus three in the morning and it's
been going pretty well i'm a bit
knackered but my this is fun i'm
building a structure atom by atom
let me flip the camera around so you can
see what i'm doing
so
this is a little rectangle of atoms each
gold atom pushed in place
um
before and after hopefully will appear
on the screen
each blob there each circle is a single
gold atom and what i'm hoping is that we
can find some electrons within there
within that little container it probably
needs to be compacted a little bit more
and the atoms move together a little bit
more but it's getting there it's it's
getting there
you could ask a very very valid question
ask is could you automate this yes
it could be automating a number of
groups um have automated the
manipulation of atoms using scanning
probes
and
yes it's definitely something that's on
the agenda for us indeed we've we've
made moves in that direction before um
there is something to be said though
with a brand new instrument like this
one to sort of
get your hands dirty doing the
manipulation um sort of
by hand as it were and um getting a feel
for how the instrument behaves how the
feed like feedback loop behaves etc
um though i must admit
it getting to half three in the morning
um perhaps it really should be a
question of handing it over to the
computer because the computer doesn't
get tired quite like we do so spend some
time trying to build structures atom by
atom to contain electrons and then
realize well nature can do the job
even better and
i don't have to spend a lot of time
putting things together moving atoms
across the surface
so this particular gold surface we found
these beautiful triangular structure
that is or you can see the scale bar at
the bottom
10 nanometers so it's about 10
nanometers edge and it's pretty much a
perfect equilateral triangle that's fun
enough but over here what we can see and
it's overwriting the previous image but
what you can see is the electron waves
that are trapped within that structure
it's absolutely stunning
it's so much fun just changing the
energy and watching how these waves
these wave patterns change i am blown
away by the stability and just
capability this instrument it is
fantastic
out of the can and you can glue a tip
onto it
or blue tech oh you can yeah you can
perhaps not in in the real case we don't
blue tack it on we actually do glue it
on but actually the gluing is probably
just about that accurate
[Music]